hi everyone i'm jim poglio currently i'm
a simon's quantum possible fellow and at
simon ctu and used berkeley and john
halls by women's and link i will be a
postal associate at center for
theoretical physics at mit
uh today i would like to talk about
quantum scientific notation
um as we know and all as you we just
know introduced by d and the quantum
computers can make use of some quantum
mechanical phenomena such as
superstition or entanglement to perform
certain computation so these pictures
show some
currently near-term one device built by
some famous companies such as ibm google
and also other research groups
and
why we are concerned with quantum
computers because they can significantly
outperform classical computers for
certain computational problems
and i would say and currently are
tremendous and numbers of war focusing
on foreign computers for solving linear
dynamics and discrete models such as the
hamiltonian simulations which has been
covered by this part and also another
large class of problems based on the
quantitative reasons for solving systems
of linear equations now i would like to
start by validity algorithms
and
so this is basic problem model so the
sort of quantum linear system problem so
considering lab we have some certain
description of a certain s-path and by a
linear system as shown in equation one
so where we should assume the sparsity s
that means a
parameter up about the number of
non-zero entries each column edge rows
in elemental a is significantly smaller
than the dimension so for such a kind of
uh
sparse linear systems and we aim to
efficiently solve a problem under some
capacities that is generally uh
smaller than the classical liaison
solvents so for lab problems and so
contributors is able to produce a
quantum coding of such an inverse
solution and with such a capacity and
which has a linear scaling in terms of
response vs initiating in terms of
recognition number kappa and has a
polynomial dependence in terms of a
dimensionality and which has a
exponential speed in terms of the
dimension and compared to the classical
linear system servers here i would like
to emphasize that way it's no hope to
produce all the
entries of the the vectors x and because
you would take at least linear n however
and uh maybe it is the whole plan under
some measurements it is possible to take
some problem management to answer
certain questions fascinating castlevale
reasons
um yeah so and after we discussed the
quantity and system solvers now we are
focusing on more competitive realistic
problems than the so-called scientific
computation problems there are some
pretty famous models for problems such
as the
modeling climate changes and the model
spread of epidemics and how to model a
derivative surprise
so for such a problem the basic or we
can say the crucial challenges in terms
of the design of chronic horizon is the
gap between the linearity of quantum
mechanics to the real-world systems with
many body non-linear as well as
statistically interactions so my
research based on uh
based on basically speaking my
resistance aims to address these three
types of different difficulties but
today i would like to just focus on
online ones
so why not energy which is extremely
difficult in quantum building even
harder than the cluster computing um
basic speeding and you can
be databased to the
so-called quantum coding theory in
quantum mechanics but here i would like
to mainly cover the difficulty in two
aesthetics from the algorithm science
and the previous algorithm i would say
before the 2020 and the previous final
reasons for solving general nonlinear
differential equations
must take exponential time and space
capacity for that problems
and on the other side we have some lower
bound results on addressing these
problems and actually and people have
strong people have shown that the
nominees can imply polynomial time
solutions for mp complete and even for
sharpie problems and for particular case
of nonlinear sharing equations one can
show for
if lehigh sounds strongly nominated and
the strong knowledges and the quantum
properties can must have a worst case
type capacity explanation key
so this is the reason that why people
think the 98 is difficult and actually
it was a long-standing open problem in
the field of quantum computing until we
try to target
um so for lab problems and our
contribution is like we developed the
first efficient lamin efficient means
polynomial time quantities for weekly
dissipating non-differential equations
we also given at the almost tight lower
bound results showing that strongly
nonlinear ones are generally insertable
so this paper was published in peanuts
and also it has been these presents
being covered by the quantize
medians
and so now we can look at the problem
models we are interested in addressing
such kinds of the
quantum non-eod problems so i'm showing
in equation two
so and for such a kind of
a system of the n-dimensional projectile
these systems and here and f2 f1 f0 are
the matrix of vectors to represent the
quadratic couplings linear hubslings and
linear homogeneities and we end to
simulate systems starting from initial
state to a final state and we further
assume this system should be uh where 0
is dissipated that means the real path
of added values of f1 should be
negative and for instance for the
so-called borders equation which is kind
of one-dimensional navier starts
equation satisfies such a condition
under some proper boundary conditions
and even such a very general problem
model and we define an important
parameter r as shown in here and
it's used to quantify the nonlinear
distribution related to the linear
dissipation that means if r is small
that means the linear dissipation
dominates the
and other terms so we say a small r
represents a weightedly nonlinear system
so if i small maybe it's possible to
solve a problem
so yeah that is then so we consider such
a framework and we'll consider how to
perform a proper linearization for
targeted english problems and regarding
linearization maybe you will think about
sun eye effection based on the linear
japanese and which would imagine like
like this toy model so if we replace u
square by u0 times u and then least
linearization cannot work in a long time
and so we need to sit for some long time
and stable
linearization method so repeat our
old-school tiny so-called
columnarization here is the base
framework so first of all we can invade
a n-dimensional nonlinear system into an
infinite dimensional linear
and suddenly for the algorithm side we
must truncate the system to go back to a
finite dimensional system and actually
the key is like we need to
preserve the dimensionality to be at the
most polynomial in terms of n and for
such a truncation we can prove the
truncation error converge under the
condition i smaller than one so the
previous parameter r can be understood
as a certain convergence radius
so and given such a linearized system we
have to introduce the sulfur quantum
linear system region so for which we can
perform proper discretization and
perform the quantity in system solvers
to solve a problem to perform to provide
a quantum coding of the solution with
the capacitive polarization in terms of
n that is base framework
so here is the basic uh statement of our
main theorem even the condition is more
than one there is a quantity to
efficiently produce such a quantum state
corresponding to the solution
and here i would like to emphasize that
the mass contribution that means
independent of quantum computing we
improve the previous best known
convergence analysis of columnarization
and our state-of-the-art analysis has
been applied to classical not only a
controlled series and classical safety
which is all independent of quantum
profits
and on the other side why i say it's
almost thai result because on the other
side we also give a lower bound
result in under the condition one ice
larger than or equal to spell of two
that means we only leave a very narrow
gap between one and stream of two
so this is basic result and we show an
instant of such a problem such as and
informalism must have worst case
high capacity exponential in t
so the proof stretch is as follows first
of all we know some basic lower bound
results in the quantum information
theory such as the we use the harness of
distinguishing two or seven or
non-original quantum states and suddenly
there is a well-known effect of
butterfly effect
variously is the so-called initial
sensitivity that means if we are given
two kinds two possibilities of initial
states with a very small
difference
after the very short evolution time the
small difference will result in a large
variation like this future and one
solution process and the other and
osteons that mean we will fastly change
the
the states of this strange two states
and
under the same evolution
so given such a capability and so if
there exists a chronologism that can
efficiently simulate such a chaotic
system that means it provides an
efficient way to efficiently distinguish
not all surname quantum states which is
believed to be impossible so
based on such results we show unless the
worst case time capacity is financial
inquiry for army supreme reasons for
such example
oh finally i would like to briefly
travel applications of series and errors
in recent years in light
so the first application is for flu and
plasma dynamics and
between switching only 30 for weight
early 90 differential equations so
actually
pneumatical resistance some a little bit
uh theoretical resulting shows that our
ionization was for low nano
lose the so-called laminar flows and
maybe we cannot target for turbulence so
and based on some recent results and i
was invited to give a semi-primary talk
at the annual meeting of aps division of
fluid dynamics and last year and the
second application is for the control
series like it can be used to find
certain charters or star dealer
reachability problems
certainly and we also study how to apply
the liaison reason for the certain scm
model which is well known for modeling
the spread of endemius and we started
under the so-called rapid vaccination
condition and our reason was for the
realistic parameters you know what and
finally and we also study applications
in in economy and
ecologies and uh we can use litharism to
solve some certain knowledge pds and
which is used to model like predator
prey cycles or economy models and
for the realistic world
this is a final page maybe and uh uh
here during my talk i would like to
cover like the only cover the
breakthrough and for the non-dynamics
and it's connected to many types of
applications and regardless of
reputations for odmpd's it can also be
used to study networks particularly for
environmental problems it can be used to
start illustrating false for
optimization or machine learning
problems it can be used to solve some
equations
showing the optimal control always
personally and
my research also covers other types of
studies like how to simulate many body
systems including classical and quantum
mechanical systems from the quantum
dynamics to the molecular dynamics and
lastly i also try to study some
polynomial quantum speedarts for some
stochastic process like what how to
design pronations for speed are like
london the parallel masses or general
mcmcr reasons well how do you see some
reason for option pricing or for
decision making or reasons and yeah
that's it thank you
thank you very much
[Applause]
any questions
when you say quantum over what are the
difference between standard od
yes can you repeat the question yeah
yeah yeah sure and uh so the question is
that what's the difference between the
classical and frontal non-led problems
as shown in these
slides and
basic speeding first of all and
given a certain equations and the
initial state is a quantum encoding of
the initial value or just a data set i
mean we need to have some procedure to
upload the data into control or tool
quantum computer so we have a quantum
encoding of the initial condition then
output is also a quantum encoding of the
final state i mean we try to produce the
pronunciation the corresponding maybe as
shown in here uh quantum state and the
ut and stored in a quantum computer
which is corresponding to the
classical state so as we introduce our
beginning so there's no hope to produce
all the entries of these these high
dimensional vectors but we can we need
to perform some certain measurements to
to properly tighten some projections of
the batters to answer some sort of
questions
okay
thanks yeah maybe we can take the
remaining questions uh over the coffee
break so thanks to all the speakers of
the session
um we break now for half an hour and
then we'll come back 3 30 to
finish off the talks for the day thanks
everyone